bonsoir nous sommes le 30 octobre merci
de nous rejoindre sur tv fil 78 il est
18 heures si vous nous suivez en direct
voici les titres de ce set 8 l'aktu son
contrôle d'identité mouvementée avait
déclenché des émeutes durant le mois de
juillet a traversé en drap de lin qui
portent le voile intégral comparaissait
ce matin devant la justice pour outrage
à policiers port d'une tenue du simulant
le visage dans l'espace public
elle n'a pas fait le déplacement son
procès a été renvoyé au 11 décembre
les feuilles mortes sur les voix d'ange
est pris très au sérieux par la sncf en
dehors des accidents
cela peut également entraîner des
retards dans le trafic attrape le centre
de maintenance s'adapte pourrait limiter
le phénomène
le salon du chocolat porte de versailles
à paris c'est parti les gourmands se
retrouveront jusqu'au 3 novembre
quelques 250 exposants sont présents
pour cette 19ème édition parmi eux des
yvelinois
nous les avons suivis à l'image du jour
c'est bien sûr elle arrivait sur la base
aérienne de vélizy-villacoublay des ex
otages français enlevés il ya plus de
trois ans sur un site minier dans le
nord du niger par al qaïda ils ont été
accueillis par leurs familles par
françois hollande elle les conditions de
leur libération restent inconnus même si
l'on évoque une rançon de 20 millions
d'euros
pierre legrand de couffé daniel larribe
marc ferret et thierry dol quatre hommes
travaillant notamment pour le géant du
nucléaire areva installé d'ailleurs à
montigny le bretonneux areva qui se
refuse à tout commentaire
je vous propose en revanche est
d'écouter à présent le président
françois hollande sur le tarmac de la
base yvelinoise ainsi que les filles de
l'ex otages daniel larribe
je veux saluer leur courage
trois en trois ans d'épreuves d'attentes
de souffrance ils sont non seulement des
hommes qui ont subi ces moments mais ce
sont de grands citoyens français qui ont
fait honneur dans leur captivité à la
france nos quatre amis vont retrouver
c'est déjà fait leur famille et leur vie
je veux leur souhaiter tout ce que peut
on peut dire à des hommes qui ont
maintenant la liberté c'est à dire le
bonheur vous de retrouver quand votre
papa c'est impossible
là il est parti juste pour trois heures
on le retrouve du bonheur forcément
ringside les plus enclavées outre-mer
rappelle même pas j'étais complètement
dans le flot d'émotions donc voilà il
m'a demandé si j'avais fini mes études
de médecine entre autres pour se
rattacher du concret comment ça va se
passer cette journée qu'est ce que ça
représente
c'est le début d'une nouvelle vie le
procès de cassandra blanc renvoyé au 11
décembre elle s'était opposé à un
contrôle de police à trappes cet été un
contrôle motivée par le port d'une tenue
dissimulant son visage elle devait
comparaître ce matin à versailles mais
seulement son avocat étaient présents
afin de déposer une question prioritaire
de constitutionnalité contre la loi
interdisant le port du voile intégral
dans l'espace public une loi en vigueur
depuis l 2011 ce recours est une
première le procès est donc suspendu
violaine thorez et le diwan cassandra
belin devait comparaître ce mercredi à
versailles pour outrage à policier et
port du voile intégral sur la voie
publique
son procès a finalement été renvoyé au
11 décembre prochain
absente elle était représentée par son
avocat qui a déposé une question
prioritaire de constitutionnalité contre
la loi interdisant le port du voile
intégral dans l'espace public une
première concernant cette loi en vigueur
depuis 2011
si on met en place une loi
en effet une loi liberticide mais qu'on
vient dire aux services de police évitez
d éviter de la verbalisée parce qu' il
peut y avoir des émeutes dans les
quartiers ou que sais-je c'est qu'il ya
quelque chose qui va pas donc il faut
que je faire bouger les lignes
ce que je souhaiterais c'est qu' une
interdiction générale de la cible
dissimulation du visage dans l'espace
public que c'est toi ton il soit
totalement abroger cette loi entre les
mains des policiers
en europe c'est un permis de chasse et
la femme voilée intégralement couverts
philippe bataille affirme avoir la
preuve qu'un des policiers tenait des
propos à caractère islamophobe sur
facebook avant et après les faits
l'avocat des fonctionnaires de son côté
n'évoque pour l'instant aucune poursuite
contre ces propos larmes de destruction
massive de la part des gens qui sont
dans le radicalisme islamique et si
c'est à dire qu'on ne peut pas parler
d'islam sens et islamophobe
ça me paraît un choix très dangereux
quand à la question prioritaire de
constitutionnalité déposées par la
défense il rappelle qu'elle a fait
l'objet d'un examen général avant sa
promulgation et qu'il n'y a aucune
raison juridique d'en demander un nouvel
examen
c'est une nouvelle illustration de ce
que les gens qui se prévalent sous
couvert d'un vernis religieux d'un
argumentaire qui est en réalité
politique utilise toutes les voies de
droit utilise toutes les facultés qui
sont offertes par notre système
démocratique pour
pour essayer de le contrer d'ici le 11
décembre le procureur de la république
qui va prendre des réquisitions écrites
sur cette demande de qpc
c'est l'heure de l'entretien de cette
édition avec ce soir thierry quartier
bonsoir vous êtes le chef de projet anti
henry heures à la sncf aujourd'hui la
sncf qui présentait son dispositif pour
lutter contre les désagréments causés
par les feuilles mortes c'est en effet
l'automne il faut faire face aux
conditions naturelles pendant première
question le sentiment tout de même qu'on
a c'est que ça intervient chaque année
ces feuilles mortes et pour autant c'est
la première fois qu'il ya une telle
action qui est menée par la sncf
pourquoi donc les feuilles mortes arrive
tous les ans que ce soit en france ou
dans le monde entier les feuilles
tombent à certaines périodes de l'année
selon la température extérieure selon le
vent selon plein de paramètres et chaque
année est différente et donc nous on a
décidé avec le stif le syndicat des
transports d'ile-de-france d'investir
dans un dispositif qui permet de
préserver la vie des essieux lorsque la
circulation des trains est difficile
s'il ya des changements de train aussi
également peut-être alors il ya le
trafic qui augmente tout le temps on est
quand même dans une augmentation du
trafic en île de france et donc les
petits dysfonctionnements deviennent des
gros ronde parfois des grosses
conséquences puisque votre a fait que
tend à augmenter
donc les trains sont équipées de
systèmes abs voilà les voitures ça
fonctionne comment alors donc c'est ça
votre voiture 2d vous freinez sur une
plaque de verglas ou sur une zone humide
vos roues se bloquent et donc le système
c'est exactement la même chose libère un
petit peu les cieux du train lui permet
de retourner normalement ne reprendre sa
vitesse nominale et on recommence sarr
fresnes en permanence jusqu'à ce que
l'adhérence soit normal entre le rail et
la route du train magnifique ans
assystem a été mis en place
comment ça se repère au niveau de la
maintenance alors donc c'est une chaîne
industrielle qu'on a monté spécialement
sur trappe
donc elle a été implanté pour répondre à
ce besoin dit industrielle et on a
commencé les études en 2012
on a monté ça sur une première rame en
qui est équipée à rennes en 2012 après
on a fait une campagne d'essais entre
lyon et marseille pendant environ deux
semaines et on a mesuré tous les
paramètres de ce système et la chaîne a
effectivement qu'on
commencé le 26 avril on a monté en série
et on continue d'ailleurs à monter en
série ces dispositifs et ça va se
poursuivre jusqu'à quand jusqu'en mars
on aura fait 100 % du parc en 2014
aujourd'hui on est à 53 %
il faudra recommencer l'opération à
l'automne prochain non non non non ça
sera cool ou le parc sort a été modifié
opérationnel pour tout les cas on parle
que d'un parc ligne end qui vient bien
cible sur le parquet qui concerne ce
centre de maintenon l'inquiète implanté
attrape alors plus de détails sur ce
dispositif justement avant de poursuivre
cette discussion avec ce reportage
d'olivier maniscalco et de jonathan
willeman attrape oui l'automne les
feuilles tombent notamment sur les rails
de la sncf ce qui entraîne des retards
ou des suppressions de trains
tout simplement parce que des rails
encombré de feuilles mortes deviennent
l'équivalent de routes verglacées pour
nos transilien ou rer
résultat les roues s'abîme patine les
freinages sont plus longs on appelle ça
l'an rayage des trains afin de lutter
contre le problème des feuilles mortes
38 rames sont actuellement en cours
d'équipement antilles en rigueur dans
l'unité opérationnelle de trappe alors
ralenti en reyers et autres ainsi que la
baisse est à votre voiture
c'est un système qui permet en cas de
patinage ou dans rayage d'éviter le
blocage des roues on est aujourd'hui sur
la ligne n paris rambouillet paris
diderot paris mantes
ce sont des rames à deux étages qu'on
appelle entre nous les bébés de zen et
ce sont sur ces 35 v 2 n qu'on installe
des dispositifs d'anti en relayeur on
l'a fait sur la ligne l on l'a aussi
fait l'année dernière il ya deux ans sur
la ligne d du rer
de telle sorte que tout le parc
francilien soit équipé pendant l'automne
2012 près de 7000 trains avaient été
touchés par les effets du freinage ou de
l'eau rayage causé par les feuilles
mortes des arbres soit 1280 heures
perdues la région la plus touchée avait
été celle de paris rive gauche avec 165
heures de transport perdus
nous parlons d'un phénomène de saison
dans le journal de ce soir les feuilles
mortes la sncf vous l'avez vue qui doit
s'adapter afin d'éviter des conséquences
aussi bien sur le trafic
évitez également les accidents est ce
qu'il peut y avoir des conséquences
désastreuses à ses feuilles mortes qui
jonchent les voies non alors il n'y a
pas on n'est pas dans un domaine de
sécurité elles sont pour ça on est quand
même dans un domaine de préserver l'état
de l'essieu parce que quand vous
v un frottement rails contre rousset de
l'acier contre les aciers vous raboter
la roue donc elle devient un carré on
peut dire il ya un plat dessus et donc
ça il faut que ce soit repris à un
moment ou un autre dans le cycle de
maintenance donc lorsqu'on le fait une
opération de reprise de sérou bon on
arrête le parc vous pouvez pas monté
dans le drame donc on supprime des
trains donc c'est pas du tout
souhaitable
donc on permet de libérer du parc en
évitant que les trains soient arrêtées
pour des raisons de maintenance
je repose la question pourquoi ça n'a
pas été fait avant alors après le trafic
sur la ligne n a augmenté fortement
on a déjà commencé sur la ligne d
d'abord voulu vraiment mettre au point
la chaîne industrielle sur la ligne d et
après on décline progressivement on a
décliné
on peut toujours dire oui c'est trop
tard mais ce sont des investissements
très lourds qui sont des circuits validé
de validation etc
on n'investit pas de l'argent public
sans
exigence de résultats cette hauteur de
14 millions d'euros 1 ces quatre mois je
témoigne et à la sncf et puis le stif
est quelqu'un de la région qui finance
derrière tout ça il faut des hommes pour
intervenir on les a vus à travers le
reportage ce sont de nouveaux emplois ce
sont des gens qui ont été formés alors
donc on a constitué un noyau de
cheminots qui viennent un peu partout en
france donc de rennes à lille en passant
par nîmes on à constituer ce noyau de
gens qui sont très expérimentés qui ont
compagne au nez un peu le reste de des
gens qui est sont venus sur la chaîne on
peut dire c'est un tiers de très
expérimenté et les deux tiers ont été
faites par des recrutements directs
donc on a recruté des gens et ça
constituera un vous voyez un vivier
d'emplois pour la sncf transilien en
région parisienne on parle de ses
feuilles mortes et il faut lutter pour
que les trains puissent puisse passer en
tout cas ne puisse pas s'abîmer et s'est
entraîné des retards dans le trafic
ses feuilles sont aussi ramassé un mode
dispositif comme envoyer fonctionne
alors donc là jusqu'à on parlait de la
chaîne industrielle mais sinon il ya
d'autres éléments de prévention pour
éviter l' influence des feuilles donc le
premier cd laguë vous enlever les arbres
le long de la voie vous aurez plus de
problème de feuilles mortes qui tombe
dessus
c'est très lié ensuite il ya d un wagon
qu'on appelle un wagon laveurs de la
voit donc qui vient nettoyer comme un
nettoyeur haute pression
il vient chasser le film de cellulose
qui s'est constitué ou alors on aspire
carrément les feuilles par un gros
aspirateur et ça se poursuit bien
évidemment parallèle du nouveau système
qui dit nouveau système qui est mis en
place sur les différents trains ce sera
la dernière question que je vous pose et
on a tout de même le sentiment que la
sncf met l'accent sur toute la sécurité
aujourd'hui après tout ce qui a pu se
passer dans les précédents au mois tout
au long de l'année précédente
autour de ces catastrophes ferroviaires
alors la sécurité a toujours été au
coeur de la sncf et le restera c'est
notre première motivation on est on
s'assure en permanence du maintien de
cette sécurité
ce dispositif n'est pas à franchement
parler un dispositif sécuritaire il
n'intervient pas pour prévenir un
accident encore ce soit dans il
intervient pour réduire pour augmenter
la durée de vie des essieux et éviter
qu'on ait des drames d'arrêter c'est sa
première motivation mais des accidents
comme bretigny vous y pensez forcément
lorsque vous mettez en place tous ces
dispositifs automatiquement aux puits
de toute façon vous touchez un train
quand vous touchez en trinquant vont
modifier en 30 tous les éléments d'un
train ou la majorité sont quand même
lien avec la sécurité du des passagers
dont vous y pensez automatique merci à
remercier d'être venu sur ce plateau de
la sncf la sncf qui y met donc l'accent
sur le ramassage des feuilles et puis
surtout sur l'entretien de ses trains
pour circuler durant l'automne merci à
vous on continue cette édition du 7 8
l'aktu du côté de paris où s'ouvre tout
juste le salon du chocolat il revient à
chaque année comme les feuilles mortes
d'ailleurs daisy minois ils sont
présents claire combier jonathan vilma
sont allés parcourir les 20 mille mètres
carrés du site ce porte de versailles
mardi veille de l'ouverture au public du
salon du chocolat les 250 exposants
finissent de s'installer
ils viennent de partout en france et
même de l'étranger pour dévoiler leurs
nouveautés chocolatées parmi eux des
artisans évinois comme hubert baron il
est l'inventeur de ces fontaines à
chocolat géante son atelier de
fabrication se situe à andry je suis
pratiquement le seul au monde à pouvoir
se parlent à leurs 2060
ces fontaines breveté sont fabriqués à
80% à partir de matériaux français mais
ses clients sont majoritairement
étrangers des professionnels comme des
hôtels ou des restaurants
cette année il présente cette fontaine à
deux couleurs chocolat blanc chocolat
noir l'objectif est ferré prochaine une
3080 en trois couleurs un peu plus loin
nous retrouvons un chef chocolatier de
saint-germain-en-laye 19e édition de ce
salon est 19e venu pour pascal le gac
son étal est presque prêt une sculpture
à croquer et ses créations cette année
il présente trois nouveautés des bonbons
de chocolat au pain d'épicés caramel au
beurre salé ou encore parfums exotiques
mangue noix de coco et pulpe de passion
pour imaginer ses recettes il tient un
carnet de notes qu'il griffonne au gré
de ses inspirations les idées que je
vois à peu partout je note pas forcément
chez moi d'ailleurs pas dans mon atelier
part dans mon laboratoire plutôt à
l'extérieur de ce que j'entends de ce
que je vois de ce que je goûte de ce que
je sens et surtout souvent dans d'autres
métiers ça peut être dans la cuisine ça
peut être des
et plus axé sur la boulangerie la
pâtisserie etc
les exposants sont maintenant tous
installés peuvent profiter de la soirée
d'inauguration
au programme un défilé de robes en
chocolat portées par des personnalités
églantine les milieux elisa tovati
marion bartoli
et natacha polony en chocolat cacao
barry et la célèbre marque est binaire
et à quand les équipes de tv fil pour
défiler lors du salon du chocolat
toujours dans le cadre de ce salon se
tenait aussi pour les professionnels à
paris la finale du world chocolate
masters 20 chefs pâtissiers chocolatiers
qui s'affrontent depuis lundi pour
remporter le titre de champion du monde
du chocolat le principal organisateur et
cacao barry société et qui est connu
aujourd'hui dans le monde entier mais
elle est née dans les yvelines à melon
il ya toujours son siège
nous avons rencontré le français du jury
pour savoir en quoi consiste précisément
cette compétition le premier jour ils
ont eu la partie artistique
donc c'est vraiment amener les éléments
en chocolat et monter et monter leurs
pièces pour représenter leur thème leur
vision à eux de l'architecturé du goût
qui on a vraiment des choses
complètement différentes et des
techniques différentes et en général
vraiment du très beau travail
agréablement surpris donc parfait et
aujourd'hui c'était les dégustations
il avait dessert à l'assiette à faire
entre mes chocolats à dominance chocolat
qui était très important chocolat noir
bonbons enrobé de praliné et là les
dernières indications ça va être
rappel les bonbons moulé et le dernier
critère c'est le conte appelle le
travail
c'est à l'intérieur du box comment ça se
passe la dextérité l'organisation la
gestion du stress
l'hygiène et c'est plein plein plein
plein de critères de notes mais en gros
on va dire c'est l'artistique la
dégustation et travail et le vainqueur
de cette édition et italiens davide
comme à ski qui l'emportent et qui
devient donc que champion du monde du
chocolat et vous à quoi
reconnaissez-vous un bon chocolat quels
sont vos critères vos réponses au micro
de jonathan vilma pour moi c'est le d'or
comptant dans la boutique déjà on sent
la bonne odeur de chocolat frey
6-6 quand ils font à gauche c'est bien
tendres il ya s'avère donc un bon
chocolat eux
déjà à son goût je pense
votre eau sucrée ils feront pas vers eux
puis après ça dépend des parfums qu'on
est premier de compte il ya différents
chocolatier différents goûts chocolat
alors moi je sais c'est pas chocolat du
tout alors comment le reconnais va son
amertume je pense que ce sont 17 à 3 800
ko c'est la vertu à bon chocolat c'est
normalement je crois la belgique
oui oui saveurs oui oui et puis non il
ya la couleur aussi texture je suis pas
peu dire moi je le sens goût et j'ai
toujours mangé du chocolat belge
on quitte le monde du chocolat pour
celui des enfants des loisirs pendant
les vacances les enfants peuvent se
transformer le temps d'une après-midi en
véritable paysagiste le musée de la
ville de saint quentin qui leur propose
d'imaginer de créer leur espace urbain
sous forme de maquette en ateliers
pédagogiques et ludiques ou même les
parents se prêtent au jeu vous allez le
voir avec ce reportage d'aurélia de
bissy et d'élodie moines alors si passer
une petite rivière petit ruisseau
comment vous allez décider le ruisseau
où la rivière dessiner une rivière des
parcs et des jardins
c'est dans la peau de paysagistes que se
sont glissés les enfants samedi après
midi à l'initiative du musée de la ville
de saint quentin en yvelines
l'atelier de vacances la ville en herbe
propose à nos chers petits d'imaginer
leur parc urbain sous la forme d'une
maquette colorée la loi en l'occurrence
où qu'ils soient créatifs qu'il soit
quand même inventif face à une maquette
au départ est à ces aspects mais en fait
on voit bien que les résultats
ce confetti et puis surtout
ce sont des des enfants qui vivent en
général à la fin quand on y vit donc
qu'ils connaissent aussi le territoire
l'histoire de la ville nouvelle de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines c'est la ville
à la fois d'eau et de verdure donc c'est
en fait pour cette raison que ce soit de
cet atelier existe au sein du musée de
la ville comme de vrais professionnels
les enfants commence par dessiner leurs
croquis puis complète les volumes partir
de matériaux simples l'écologique des
herbes de provence en guise d' espaces
verts des épices pour tracer les chemins
objectif laisser libre cours à son
imagination en effet tirage effet un ton
si colas lâche un concert les chemins
pas là j'ai utilisé un corps tu crèves
on faire un
les chemins sont prêts je m quand tu
marques ont ici pour parler pendant ces
longs fabrique un jardin avec un jardin
avec art des pierres où on peut passer
en adhérence des arbres et et des
sculptures
un atelier participatif même les parents
se prennent au jeu et profite avec leurs
enfants d'un moment de complicité
privilégier le thème nous plaisait bien
on pense que c'est assez facile à faire
quand on aime bien la nature tous les
deux moi j'aime bien les choses manuel
donc autant participer le fait
d'utiliser des matières naturelles aussi
pour arriver à quelque chose qui peut
ressembler ce qu'on rencontre tous les
jours
dire des parcs pour les enfants les
petites forêts voilà on est sur un parc
mais équivalent utilisation des
matériaux naturels ça c'est très sympa
je dois donc on peut reproduire à la
maison aussi ça va être sympa si on a
pas finis ou si on veut refaire
carnet rose dans ce journal ils sont nés
le 9 juillet n'aura n'est goran ce sont
les deux nouveaux servent à l'arrivée au
parc zoologique de thoiry après trois
mois dans le confort de leur enclos ils
sont enfin sortis le public peut aller
rencontrer olivier maniscalco elodie
moines à thoiry de nouveaux
pensionnaires ont rejoint la réserve
zoologique yvelinoise nolan et goran de
cerval né le 9 juillet dernier font
désormais le bonheur des visiteurs du
parc animal répondu dans les savanes de
l'afrique subsaharienne le serval est
connu pour être très bon chasseur grâce
à ses grandes oreilles sont nous y est
très développé et lui permet de repérer
ses proies
c'est ensuite en bondissant sur elle
qu'il arrive à les attraper mais à
thoiry les conditions de chasse sont
différentes
nous on les nourrit tous les jours dans
la maison
après on va y avoir ce qu'on appelle de
l'enrichissement ça veut dire que bon on
va leur mettre une fois par semaine
entre autres on leur met des truites
dans le bassin qui est juste derrière
moi et du coup ils pêchent au dessus du
bassin ils vont observer et ils vont
bondir d'un seul coup dans l'eau ça leur
fait pas peur
contrairement à ce qu'on pense les faits
n'ont pas forcément peur de l'eau et du
coup il va bondir dans l'eau et attraper
sa truite dont qui chassent pour
l'instant petit nolan et goran
arriveront dans un peu plus d'un an à
maturité sexuelle afin d'éviter qu'il se
reproduise avec leurs parents les félins
sont échangées avec différents parcs
français et européens en attendant leur
départ il vous reste jusqu'au 11
novembre si vous souhaitez venir les
observer avant la trêve hivernale
notre dossier halloween débuté lundi se
poursuit aujourd'hui avec un atelier
autour de la confection de costumes
l'estaminet à magny les hameaux qui
revêt pour quelques jours les couleurs
d'halloween
parents et enfants préparent les
déguisements en vue d'un défilé le 31
octobre
diaby si cette semaine à l'estaminet un
magny les hameaux
les enfants se préparent à fêter
halloween on peut faire plein de choses
aux décors on prépare et on va prendre
des bonbons avant le défilé du jeudi 31
octobre et la collecte de bonbons
une fois se mettre au travail création
des décors confection de déguisements
il ne reste que quelques jours pour être
fin prêt on fait des costumes pour l'ado
une police enfants pour qu'ils se marre
bien le jour
deux défilés et on y fait de la couture
ou en effet
des petits trucs tu es sympa on a fait
avec une autre idée on fait comme la
tétine dit d
comment dire on invente aussi j'adore
les enfants j'aime bien être avec eux et
puis je donne un peu de temps vu que je
suis en vacances
oh
copains ou copines donner un peu de son
temps et partager des moments en famille
c'est aussi l'objectif de cet atelier
on essaye de travailler avec les parents
et les enfants même temps un père amener
des familles qui sont un peu isolés les
mamans qui sont à la maison qui
travaillent pas et pendant six jours les
vacances scolaires elles ont pas
beaucoup d'occupations parce que l ont
pas les moyens pour payer les frais des
loisirs et l'objectif c'est de ramener
ces familles
ces femmes là l'erreur et faire de
rencontres entre les mamans les enfants
jeanne et ma fille parce qu'elle est
tout seul je l'expliquais gédé qui va
avoir des enfants
voilà tu vas voir faire beaucoup de
choses qu'elle était très contente
en même temps moi aussi j'aimerais bien
voir des mamans parler partager quoi
qu'est ce qu'ils font là et c'est bien
ce qu'ils font les enfants défileront
déguisés jeudi 18 heures dans le
quartier du buisson
et effrayant effectivement c'est la fin
de ce journal je vous retrouve demain
jeudi toujours en direct à 18h pour une
nouvelle édition du 7 8 l'aktu les
programmes qui se poursuivent sur
téléfilm
oui